MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS BATES.
BATES HERE MORNING.
MORNING HERE ROTH.
ROTH HERE WILK.
WILK HERE ATKINS HERE HERE AND I
BEFORE WE GET TO OUR MAIN ITEM
I'M GOING TO ASK IF I CAN GET.
CONSENT CALENDAR OF ITEM NUMBER
TWO THE BILL REFERRALS ITEM
THREE SUBCOMMITTEES.
AN ITEM FOR THROUGH THIRTEEN
WITCHER FLORIDA KNOWLEDGE MINCE.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
WE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BATES.
BATES HI MONNING MONNING AYE
ROTH.
ROTH AYE WILK WILK AYE ATKINS
AYE INSIDE THANK YOU THAT PASSES.
FIVE ZERO AND OUT WELCOME YOU
WERE HERE ON PICTURE DAY SO ALL
WE ALL LOOK OUR BEST --
PHOTOGRAPH DAY I WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND INVITE OUR APPOINTEE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES.
I AN ASK THOMAS PORTER TO COME
UP.
AS THE OUR APPOINTMENT TO THE
DIRECTOR OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME.
WE WOULD INVITE YOU TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OF FOLKS THAT MAY
HAVE COME WITH YOU TODAY.
A I IF YOU WOULD LIKE AND THEN.
DO YOUR OPENING COMMENTS REMARKS
AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT INTO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
I BEFORE I SAID.
I WILL -- INTRODUCE YOU TO MY
FAMILY -- MY WIFE REBEKAH PORTER
[inaudible]
MY SISTER [inaudible]
THE LAST [inaudible]
WELCOME -- MY YOUNGER SON ISAIAH.
OLDER SON MOTION.
MY MOTHER IN LAW GLORIA
EISENBERG.
AND MACKENZIE PRINGLE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WELCOME TO THE ENTIRE FAMILY.
THIS MUST BE A BIG DEAL.
NOW I KNOW.
SOME OF IT IS IT IS FOR
CALIFORNIA -- TO SOMEBODY.
AND MADAM PRO TEM -- ATKINS --
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU ALL.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. FOR
HEARING ME TODAY -- I A HAVE TO
ALSO -- BANK GOVERNOR NEWSOME --
FOR APPOINTING ME.
EARLY IN HIS HIS -- AT TIME AS
GOVERNOR I WAS -- VERY HAPPY
THAT I WAS WAS ABLE TO IT JOIN
THE THE EMERGENCY SERVICES TEAM --
AND FOR THE STATE AND FOLLOW --
CAN PAMELA AND THAT WAS IT'S
BEEN A VERY -- HUMBLING MOMENT
FOR ME TO BE.
SITTING IN THE SEAT BEFORE YOU
AND PUT HERE BY THOSE THOSE
EFFORTS OF SO MANY OTHERS -- I
THINK WHAT I WANT -- TO REALLY
FRAME THIS WHERE WHERE I SEE US
IN CALIFORNIA IS.
IS -- RELATED TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND THE LANDS THAT THAT HAS PUT
ON ALL OF OUR ACTIVITIES -- MY
OPERATIONS UNDER CAL FIRE ARE
POISED TO DO -- JUST WHAT THEY
HAVE BEEN DESIGNED TO DO RESPOND
TO WILDFIRES -- RESPONSE TO THE
FOREST HEALTH ISSUES THAT THAT
NEED TO BE DEALT WITH -- BUT
THIS CLIMATE CHANGE -- THE KIND
OF LANDS THAT WERE UNDER IS --
REALLY A CALL TO ACTION THAT WE
HAVE NEVER SEEN IN OUR
GENERATION.
WE ARE GOING TO BE -- RESPONDING
TO THE KIND OF EMERGENCIES THAT
WE'VE BEEN SEEING WHETHER THEIR
FIRES OR FLOODS OR OR OTHER
TYPES OF EMERGENCIES -- FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
AND I SEE -- THAT NOT ONLY ARE
IS CAL FIRE POISED TO DO SUCH
RESPOND -- BUT CAL FIRE IS VERY
MUCH IN A POSITION.
TO I HAVE SOME POSITIVE AFFECT.
ON THE FUTURE.
AND MEET THE KING CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMBING GOALS.
AND HELPED WITH THAT PROCESS --
FORESTRY FORESTRY IS ABSOLUTELY
ONE OF THE KEY ELEMENTS -- TO
REVERSING.
WHERE WE ARE WITH THE IT WITH
THE CLIMB?
AND HELPING CAL CALIFORNIA TO BE
A LEADER IN THE WORLD IN THAT --
AT THAT AREA.
WE ALSO -- ARE A LEADER IN THE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF OF FIRE SAFE
BUILDING CODES AND THOSE KIND OF
THINGS THROUGH OUR FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAM IN OFFICE OF
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
AND THEN OUR OUR RESPONSE
CAPABILITIES ARE SECOND.
IN THE WORLD [inaudible]
AND I'M GONNA CLOSE WITH -- A A
VERY BIASED STATEMENT ON MY PART.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT I HAVE
WORKED FOR CALIFORNIA FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT CAL FIRE IS
THE BEST DEPARTMENT.
AND IS IN THE IS POSITIONED.
IN A PLACE. TO CARRY THIS BALL
INTO THE FUTURE.
AND REALLY SHOW THE WORLD.
WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING?
AND DO THAT WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALL ITS MIGHT
BEHIND.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME HAVE AN
OPENING STATEMENT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M GONNA
LOOK TO MY LEFT AND START WITH
SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM MADAM
CHAIR. ONE I THINK THE DIRECTOR
DESIGNATE CONGRATULATE YOU ON
THE GOVERNOR'S CONFIDENCE IN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MANY YEARS OF
SERVICE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR
FAMILY AND THANK THEM FOR
SHARING YOU WITH US I KNOW
THERE'S PRIME IN MANY FIRE
SEASONS WHERE.
YOU'VE BEEN A RARE OCCURRENCE ON
THE HOME FRONT -- THAT THAT DOES
LEADING TO ONE OF MY QUESTIONS
WITH OUR ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATIONS AND WE'VE HAD SOME.
OPPORTUNITIES I THINK WE FIRST
MET AT THE SOBRE HONEST FIRE IN
MY DISTRICT [inaudible]
WHICH WAS.
LARGE AND DEVASTATING
FORTUNATELY MOSTLY.
TO THE FOREST IN NOT TO TO
HUMANS ALTHOUGH THERE WERE SOME.
NOTABLE CASUALTIES.
FROM THE GOVERNOR HAS IDENTIFIED
A THIRTY FIVE FIRE PREVENTION
PROJECTS AS THE CORNERSTONE OF
THE COMMUNITY WHILE FIRE
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION REPORT.
WHEN IF YOU COULD SHARE WITH THE
COMMITTEE THAT TIME LINE ON THAT
WHAT'S THE CURRENT STATUS REPORT
AND HOW WERE THOSE?
COMMUNITIES IDENTIFIED.
THANK YOU SENATOR MONNING THE
THE THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS THAT
ARE.
CALLED OUT -- IN THE FORTY FIVE
DAY REPORT ALL CALL IT -- ARE
ARE ALL EQUAL PRIORITY I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT'S THAT'S CLEAR
EVERYONE OF THOSE PROJECTS WE
WILL WE WILL BE TAKING AS THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IN THE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA THAT IT'S IN --
THE TIME FRAME -- FOR ACTING ON
THOSE -- IS START AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE -- SOME OF THEM THAT
HAD SOME OF THE SEQUEL WORK --
AHEAD DONE AHEAD OF TIME -- ARE
READY TO START TODAY -- THE REST
OF THEM ARE IN A RIDLEY -- VERY
SHORT REVIEW PROCESS THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH -- THE SECRETARIES --
OF NATURAL RESOURCES AND EPA ON
AN EXPEDITED -- REVIEW OF AND
THAT THAT INCLUDES THE BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES ON THAT
WILL BE -- EMPLOYED ON EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THOSE PROJECTS.
GREAT WELL THANK YOU AND THEN --
ALSO JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP YOU
SHARED SOME INTERESTING
INFORMATION YESTERDAY.
RESPONDER FATIGUE THE CONCERNS
OF LONGER FIRE SEASON LONGER
TIME OF SEPARATION FIREFIGHTERS
AND FAMILIES.
IN JUST THE PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL.
FATIGUE AND SOMETIMES TRAUMA ON
THE FRONT LINES OF FIRE.
HELL IS CAL FIRE APPROACHING
THAT MAYBE YOU COULD SHARE WITH
THE COMMITTEE WHAT SOME O THE
EXPECTED A DAYS OF SERVICE ARE
WHEN YOU'RE.
IN ACTIVE FIRE FIRE FIGHTING
MODE BECAUSE I FOUND IT KIND OF
AMAZING THE CONTINUOUS DAYS OF
WORK.
YES -- WE WE ASK A LOT OF OF OUR
STATE FIREFIGHTERS -- AN
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS ACROSS THE
BOARD -- SOME OF THOSE ARE
FIREFIGHTERS THEY'RE THEY'RE
ALSO SUPPORT THROUGH ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES THAT RESPOND --
BUT I'LL SPEAK ON BEHALF OF CAL
FIRE WE WE WE TRULY HAVE PASSED --
OUR EMPLOYEES TO GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND WE WE ARE SEEING A LONGER
FIRE SEASON.
IT'S ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE DAYS
LONGER -- EVERY YEAR THAN IT HAS
BEEN -- THAN IT WAS. TWENTY TO
THIRTY YEARS AGO AND AND AND
PREVIOUS TO THAT -- SO PEOPLE
AREN'T GETTING THAT WINTER BREAK
TO START AS EARLY OR THEIR
SPRINGS THERE'S OUR ARCH CUT
SHORT -- AND SO WHAT WE'RE
FINDING IS -- THAT THE
TRADITIONAL -- JUST GO GO GO --
IS IS VERY DIFFICULT TO MAINTAIN
AND THE WHAT WE BEN -- AND IT'S
IT'S NOT A ABSOLUTE FOR MORE --
FOURTEEN DAYS AND TWENTY ONE
DAYS BUT THOSE ARE THE TWO
BREAKING POINTS THAT WE USE --
WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL A IS OUT FOR
FOURTEEN DAYS THEY NEED TO HAVE
A RESET FOR A DAY?
IF IT'S IF THEY'RE GONNA BE OUT
FOR TWENTY ONE DAYS IT'S A TWO
DAY RESET.
AND AS IT STANDS -- IN IN OUR
INFORMAL POLICY NOW -- WE WE WE
DON'T HAVE A MECHANISM TO RETURN
THEM HOME AT THAT POINT -- IS
THAT IS NOT A REQUIREMENT AND
THAT IS DOING THAT ONE OR TWO
DAY BREAK THAT IS TRUE AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT THAT IS
CONCERNING TO ME THAT WE HAVE --
FIREFIGHTERS AND EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS THAT ARE OUT FOR
TWENTY ONE DAYS MAY HAVE TWO
DAYS OF OF RECOVERY IN A HOTEL
AND GO BACK TO WORK FOR ANOTHER --
TWENTY ONE DAYS AND THAT CAN
HAPPEN OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
AND FIREFIGHTERS **** AT TIMES
HAVE BEEN OUT FOR A SIXTY PLUS
DAYS.
WITHOUT EVER GETTING HOME TO SEE
THEIR FAMILIES THAT SUBJECT TO
REVIEW CURRENTLY IS ARE THEIR
BREAKING POINT SWEAR.
ADDING AN EXTRA DAY TO RESET
WERE.
AFTER FORTY DAYS SIR FIFTY DAYS
YOU GET A WEEK OR SOMETHING --
THAT WOULD HELP.
IT'S THE A WHO WE NEED TO REVIEW
THE ENTIRE OUR OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM
AND PART OF THE PART OF THE
DIFFICULTY WE'VE HAD IN.
IN MAKING ADJUSTMENTS ON THE FLY
AND I'LL SAY THAT IS WHILE THESE
THESE -- SEASONS HAVE BEEN
WEARING ON IS THAT WE WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH FIREFIGHTERS.
IN ORDER TO BACK FILL THE
COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE MAKING TO
EVERY FIRE.
AND SO -- WE'RE SHORT THE BODIES
TO DO ACTUALLY WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO BE DOING -- AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT I HAVE BEEN
WORKING THROUGH -- THIS BUDGET
AND IN EVERY -- BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL THAT WE PUT FORWARD WE
ARE STAFFING APPROPRIATELY --
THE THE ENGINES AND THE THE
DIFFERENT APPARATUS.
THAT NEED TO BE COVERED WITH THE
PROPER NUMBER OF OF POSITIONS
PER SEAT -- AND TRYING TO WORK
WHERE WE CAN TO BOLSTER -- THE
AREAS WHERE WERE SHORT THANK YOU
AND THEN ALONG THESE LINES MY
FINAL QUESTION MADAM CHAIR BUT
YOU ALSO SHARED SOME OF THE
INNOVATION AND COMMITMENT ONSITE
COUNSELING SERVICES AND COULD
YOU JUST SHARE THE PROGRESS OF
OF SOME OF THAT.
IN THE INNOVATION THAT'S UNDER
WAY THANK YOU SENATOR MONITOR
EIGHT MONTHS MONEY FOR BRINGING
THAT BACK -- THAT THAT IS OUR
EMPLOYEES SUPPORT SERVICES
PROGRAM AND IT IS -- PART OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGET THAT IS MOVING
FORWARD -- IT IS A PROGRAM THAT
WE HAVE.
SEVERAL EMPLOYEES THAT ARE
ALREADY A PART OF ABOUT SEVEN
STATEWIDE THIS WOULD INCREASE
THAT -- BY WITH ANOTHER --
FOURTEEN AND IT IS A PROGRAM
THAT -- THAT ALLOWS US TO GO.
TO THE FIREFIGHTERS THAT.
DAD I AM BE WHERE THEY THEY ARE
IN ORDER TO TAKE CARE OF THEM.
AND THE TAKE CARE OF THEIR
EMOTIONAL NEEDS AND AND OTHER
NEEDS THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE THAT
THEY CAN'T TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES -- ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY'RE OUT ON STRIKE TEAM
ASSIGNMENTS OR OR AS WE SAID I
CAN'T GET HOME FOR FOUR WEEKS ON
END -- AND SO THAT THAT IS A
PROGRAM THAT WE ARE VERY MUCH
OF ANOTHER VALUE TO THAT --
PROGRAM IS -- WE WE DEPLOY AT
TRAILER THAT HAS THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN IT -- AT LARGE
LARGE AND EXTENDED FIRES -- THAT
HAVE TEAMS ON THEM.
AND AND THAT SERVICE IS
AVAILABLE TO ALL OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS THAT WOULD BE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- THE FEDERAL -- OUR
FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS -- OUT OF
STATE RESOURCES IF THEY'RE
HAVING ISSUES -- ANYBODY CAN GO
TO THOSE THAT TRAILER AND GET
THE SAME KIND OF SUPPORT NOW.
THANK YOU IN AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS ON ON YOUR
CONFIDENCE THE GOVERNOR HAS A
NEW AND I THINK YOU'LL FIND WE
DO AS WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE [inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
LET ME ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MOM.
THE GOOD SENATOR TO MY LEFT
SENATOR MONEY -- ON AT YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND JOB CERTAINLY
THE RESPECT THAT YOU HAVE
MOUNTED ACTUALLY -- THROUGHOUT
YOUR CAREER WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME OF
THAT IN TERMS TO YOUR BACKGROUND.
I KNOW WHEN WE ON ME OUT TO MY
OFFICE DIRECTOR.
MICK CAN I CALL YOU THAT THAT'S
NOT BAD LUCK RIGHT I'M A LITTLE
FOR YOU SO YOU'RE IN ANYWAY --
ABOUT MY COMMUNITY THE SENATE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT HAVE --
SUFFERS IN YEARS PAST US
SEVERELY WITH WILDLAND FIRES AND
THE COMMUNITIES BILL TRIED OUT
TO THAT -- INTERFACE SO
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ISSUES ARE
CERTAINLY THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
CALIFORNIA OR TO ENSURE THAT.
THAT IS BEING MAINTAINED AND
COMMUNITIES COULD YOU SHARE WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND CERTAINLY ON
THE PEOPLE HERE ALL YOUR ROLE IN
THAT AND GOD.
IT'S BEEN EFFECTIVE CERTAINLY --
IN SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY -- THAT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IS BEEN
ONGOING AND PROBABLY IS BEING
RAMPED UP AS WE SEE WHAT
HAPPENED WITHOUT THE LATEST
WHILE BUYERS.
ABSOLUTELY SENATOR AND AND THE
THE THE IMPORTANCE OF DEFENSIBLE
SPACE -- IS IS VERY CLEAR --
WHERE DEFENSIBLE SPACE IS
MAINTAINED -- AND THAT IT THAT
IS AT THE LANDOWNERS EXPENSE AND
LANDOWNERS ACTION -- WHERE IT IS
MAINTAIN THE HOMES ARE LESS
LIKELY TO BURN -- IT IS NOT A
SILVER BULLET AS AS I MENTIONED
NONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY.
OF THEIR OWN IS A SILVER BULLET.
BUT DEFENSIBLE SPACE IS
SOMETHING THE LANDOWNER CAN DO.
AND AND IT'S IMPORTANT SO BY A
US.
AND AND AND I'M GONNA TALK TO
THIS FROM THE CAL FIRE
PERSPECTIVE AND THEN I'M GONNA
ADD THE CONTRACT COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE -- WHICH ORANGE
COUNTY IS -- AN ORANGE COUNTY --
EFFECTIVELY IS CAL FIRE IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND SO THAT'S THAT
IF THERE IS NO DIFFERENCE IN THE
WAY.
THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA
SHOULD BE MAINTAINED AND THE
INSPECTIONS THAT SHOULD BE DONE --
AND THEN THE FIRE FIGHTING IT
SHOULD BE DONE IN THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREAS SO -- THE
OR ORANGE COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY
UNDER -- BRIAN FANTASY IS THEIR
CIEF -- AND THEY I DO THE SAME
INSPECTIONS THAT WE DO OFFER
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND WE ARE
INSPECTING FOR COMPLAINTS WERE
LOOKING TO GET COMPLIANCE.
AND THE THE STATE WIDE -- GOAL
IS -- TO HAVE AN ACTIVE
INSPECTION GOING ON EVERY.
HOME IN THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY
AREA ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO WE DON'T HAVE
THE THE CAPACITY.
CURRENTLY TO DO EVERY SINGLE
YEAR -- AND WE ARE OF WORKING
TOWARD THE TARGET OF EVERY THIRD
YEAR -- AND SO THAT IS OF IT'S
IT'S A QUARTER OF A MILLION --
INSPECTIONS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO EVERY.
YEAR ACROSS THE STATE AND THAT
IS -- WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THAT SPACE?
EXCELLENT I ACTUALLY ON THE FIRE
AUTHORITY IN ORANGE COUNTY MAYBE
IT'S BEST PRACTICES I'LL WORK
THROUGH OUR AID ARE HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS.
WE HAVE TO MAINTAIN FUEL MONIC
MODIFICATIONS LAWNS.
DOWN THERE DOING SOME REGULAR
COMMUNICATION EDUCATION BECAUSE
OUR OUR CERTAINLY LARGE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE NOT IN
EACH AWAY IS BUT THEY'VE STARTED
TO TAKE THAT ON AND I THINK.
THAT CERTAINLY BECAUSE YOU ALL
OF WORK SO CLOSELY TOGETHER AND
BEEN VERY MERITORIOUS AND YEAH
AND GETTING PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND.
THE DANGER THERE -- I ON A LAST
QUESTION AND I IN ANOTHER ONE
THAT WE DISCUSS WITH THEM
REGARDING THE EVACUATION ROUTES.
AND THE ASSISTANCE WITH THE
RESOURCES FINANCIAL TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES AS THE GOING FORWARD
AND ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE THE
MONEY WE HAD WHEN I WAS ON THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE HAD.
TO NOT APPROVED -- A COUPLE OF
PROJECTS BECAUSE THEY HAD
PLANNED THAT.
AND CERTAINLY THE OVERSIGHT OF
THE FIRE THIRTY AT THAT TIME
REGARDING THAT ISSUE WAS BROUGHT
UP IN THE SEQUEL -- REVIEW AND
ALL THAT BUT I YOUR INTERFACE
WITH THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE SEE WHAT
HAPPENED AT THE CAMPFIRE.
SO COULD YOU ADDRESS HOW QUICKLY
YOU'RE ABLE TO GET OUT THE
RESOURCE OR WHAT YOU'RE DOING TO
ENSURE THAT THE RESOURCES CAN BE
THERE. FOR EXISTING AND
CERTAINLY PLANNED FUTURE PLANNED
COMMUNITIES. TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE THOSE YOUR AND AND RELATED
TO FUTURE COMMUNITIES -- THAT'S
WHERE THE LAND USE PLANNING A
PIECE OF WHAT I AM IN MY OPENING
IS SO IMPORTANT.
AND THE ENGAGING EARLY AND AND
THE THE SAFETY ELEMENT OF OF
GENERAL PLANS AND ENSURING THAT.
FOR ALL SUBDIVISIONS AND
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S GOING FORWARD
THAT WE'RE MAKING SURE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL -- AND AGAIN SO WE
WE HAVE AN ADVISORY -- MECHANISM
HERE AND THEN WHEN IT COMES TO
THE TO THE VERY HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES -- THOSE PLANS
DâN ARE REVIEWED AND APPROVED
BY THE BOARD OF FOREST AND FIRE
PROTECTION -- THOSE SAFETY
ELEMENTS AND THOSE REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE FOR SECONDARY ACCESS AND
DIFFERENT TYPES OF EGRESS WITH
THE OF OF ROADS IN THOSE KIND OF
THINGS NEED TO BE THERE ON IN.
FUTURE DEVELOPMENT THEY ALSO --
NEED TO BE CONSIDERED STRONGLY
WHEN WHEN REDEVELOPING AREAS
THAT HAVE BEEN DESTROYED BY
EITHER WILD FIRE.
OR OTHER -- NATURAL OR MAN CAVE
BECAUSE DISASTER [inaudible]
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE ARE
SEEING AND IN THE PARADISE
EXAMPLE FROM THE CAMPFIRE.
THE EVACUATION OF OF PARADISE
KHôNG CAL MCGEE ELIA.
OF WELL TRAGIC -- AND EIGHTY
FIVE PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES
[inaudible]
IT WASN'T [inaudible]
THROUGH THE MASS EVACUATION THAT
THAT HAPPENED IT WAS FROM THE
FIRE OVER RUNNING THE LOCATION
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WERE IN SOME
CASES STUCK ON SOME OF THOSE
ROADS.
BUT IT WAS A IT WAS VERY MUCH
SUCCESS -- SKYLINE -- IS A TWO
LANE EACH DIRECTION SO FOUR LANE --
ROAD.
THAT WAS TURNED INTO FOUR LANES
GOING OUT OF TOWN.
AND THEY PRACTICE THIS THEY
ACTUALLY.
DID A DRILL AND SWITCH THE
DIRECTION OF THE ENTIRE SKYLINE
TO FROM FROM -- PARADISE TO
CHICO AND A PRACTICE. TO THE
PEOPLE OF PARADISE KNEW WHAT TO
DO.
AND WHEN THAT TRIGGER WAS PULLED
THEY KNEW THAT THEY HAD THAT
CORRIDOR -- THAT CORRIDOR WAS
ALSO AN AREA WHERE A LOT OF FUEL
REDUCTION WAS DONE ALONG ALONG
THAT PART OF THE HIGHWAY.
WELL THRE WERE THOUSANDS OF
CARS ON SKYLINE HEADED OUT OF
TOWN THE FIRE WAS PASSING THEM.
DOWN BOTH SIDES OF THE OF THE
HIGHWAY.
AND THEY WERE ABLE TO MAKE IT
MAKE IT OUT AND DOWN INTO CHICO --
AND LIKE I SAID INCREDIBLY.
ONLY EIGHTY FIVE PEOPLE PERISHED
IN THAT FIRE.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
AGAIN NOW CONGRATULATIONS LE
YOU'RE CERTAINLY WELL PREPARED
TO DO A GREAT JOB IN THIS NEW
POSITIONS SO -- WE WISH YOU THE
VERY BEST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU -- THANK
YOU VENTURE.
A SIR CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT [inaudible]
INCREDIBLE RESUME [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
VERY INFORMATIVE CONVERSATION
EARLIER AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING YOUR CONFIRMATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
I DO WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON A
POINT OR TWO THAT MY COLLEAGUES
AND REMINDING MADE.
A WITH RESPECT TO THE THE THE
MENTAL WELL BEING OF YOUR FIRE
CREWS YOU KNOW THE MILITARY'S
GONE THROUGH THIS WITH
DEPLOYMENT AFTER DEPLOYMENT --
AT HISTORIC RATES OF FAR BEYOND
ANYTHING THAT -- I EVER KNEW
WHEN I WAS IN THE SERVICE -- AND
IT HAS HAD IT'S TAKING ITS TOLL
ON MILITARY MEMBERS IN THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENTS OF HAD.
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT --
MENTAL HEALTH OF PROGRAMS TO TRY
TO DEAL WTH -- WITH SOME OF
THESE ISSUES THE HAS THE
DEPARTMENT LOOKED TO THE
MILITARY IN TERMS OF BEST
PRACTICES.
OF AS YOU WERE DOING YOUR REVIEW
AND AND SETTING UP PROGRAMS --
TO DO WITH YOUR OWN.
A SIGNIFICANT -- ISSUES.
THANK YOU -- SEVEN ROTH FOR THAT --
IS STUPID -- COMMENT WE WE ARE
VERY MUCH LOOKING TO THE
MILITARY -- WE FOUND THAT.
THE MILITARY -- REALLY HAS THE
CLOSEST -- MODEL TO WHAT IT IS
WE ARE DOING WITH WITH OUR
EMPLOYEES -- THERE ARE OTHER
STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN DONE --
THAT HAVE.
BEEN MORE OF DOMESTIC KIND OF
RESPONSE TYPE OF OF STUDIES.
BUT WHAT WHAT CAL FIRE IS DOING --
AND EVEN EVEN SURPASSES WHAT THE
FOR SERVICES SEEING -- WITH
THEIR EMPLOYEES BECAUSE THEY DO
HAVE A A MORE -- FIXED ROTATION
THAN THAN CAL FIRE DOES AND SO --
LOOKING AT AT PARTICULARLY --
THE MARINE CORPS AND AND SOME OF
THE DEPLOYMENT A STUDY AND AND
CONCERNS THAT THEY'VE.
BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY -- WITH --
SUCCESSIVE DEPLOYMENTS AND AND
LENGTH OF DEPLOYMENT.
HAVE BEEN A PART OF WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT TOWARD -- WORKING
WITH THIS EMPLOYEE SUPPORT
SERVICES PROGRAM -- THE OTHER
THING THAT THAT WERE FINDING --
WHICH IS ALSO LIKE THE MILITARY
IS SLEEP DEPRIVATION AND THEN --
WHAT THAT THEN CAUSES -- IN THE
FUTURES FOR AS FAR AS ONCE
YOU'RE SLEEP DEPRIVED IT'S
HARDER TO GET BACK ON CYCLE AND
YOU BECOME.
OF MORE SLEEP DEPRIVED AND THEN
IT CHANGES THE CHEMICAL
COMPOSITION OF OF OUR BODIES IT
IT CHANGES.
HOW OUR BODIES REACT -- TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE STRESS --
CARRYING OF WEIGHT DIFFERENT
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT WHICH
ACTUALLY I WAS TALKING WITH --
ARE -- CHIEF OF THE U. S. S.
PROGRAM -- JUST THIS MORNING AND
HE'S VERY MUCH -- LOOKING INTO.
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT -- THE
STUDIES THAT ARE OUT THERE THAT
ARE THAT ARE GOING TO BE HELPFUL
IN IN HIS -- CRAFTING A PROGRAM
THAT WILL.
REALLY BE SPECIFIC TO THE
INDIVIDUAL AND THE SITUATION
THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE SEEING.
I WAS.
SEVEN IMPRESSED WITH THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE FIELDING FIELD
SUPPORT UNITS WERE --
FIREFIGHTERS CAN COMMON.
AND RECEIVE COUNSELING -- ONE
QUESTION I DO HAVE OR A POINT IN
A I WOULD HOPE THAT.
WE'RE IN WE'RE NOT AS A WAITING
FOR PEOPLE TO COME TO US I KNOW
IN THE AS I RECALL IN THE
MILITARY WE HAD A CONCEPT OF IT
WE CALL BUDDY CARE.
WHERE -- MILITARY MEMBERS WERE
TRAINED TO OBSERVE SIGNS AND
SIGNALS OF INDIVIDUALS IN
DISTRESS.
AND TO BRING THAT.
ISSUE OR THE PEOPLE TO THE
ATTENTION OF THOSE WHO CAN BEST
DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT AS YOU'RE
FORMULATING YOUR POLICIES YOU
YOU LOOK TO THAT INTO TRAINING
PROGRAMS TRAINING.
YOUR FIRE CREWS TO TO WATCH FOR
SIGNALS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO READ
DISTRESS BECAUSE OF SLEEP
DEPRIVATION -- LENGTHY
DEPLOYMENTS ARE TIME AWAY FROM
FAMILIES.
SO THAT IF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
DON'T SELF IDENTIFY FOR WHATEVER
REASON -- PRESSURE THAT EXISTS
OUT THERE WE GET THEM.
TO THE APPROPRIATE PEOPLE WHO
CAN PROVIDE THE CARE NECESSARY.
SENATORS THAT IS SO IMPORTANT
AND BODY CARE.
YOUR SUPPORT -- IS WHAT WE
TYPICALLY USE AS AS OUR TERM --
BUT IT'S THE SAME AND IT'S IT'S
WATCHING OUT FOR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
TAKING CARE OF OUR OWN.
AND THAT THERE'S NO STIGMA IN
DOING SO.
AND I'VE SEEN -- IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS OF MY CAREER AND A
VERY SIGNIFICANT CHANGE.
IN PEOPLE'S WILLINGNESS TO BE
OPEN AND TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES
THEY'RE HAVING -- AND REALLY
WORK THROUGH -- ISSUES AND AND
REACH OUT TO OUR EMPLOYEE
SUPPORT SERVICES -- IN SOME
CASES IN TWO EAP -- AS WELL WHEN
THEY GET HOME.
BUT I'M SEEING A MUCH MORE OPEN --
GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS THAT I THAT
I HAD PREVIOUSLY -- IN MY CAREER
AND IT'S IT'S IT'S HARDENING --
IT'S HARD TO TALK ABOUT A LOT OF
TIMES BUT IT IT'S IMPORTANT AND
IT'S A FEEL LIKE WE'RE AT A
PLACE WHERE THIS IS THE RIGHT
TIME.
I REALLY ENJOY THESE THESE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE THIS THIS IS.
THE IF I DO NOTHING ELSE AS
DIRECTOR.
AMONG.
THE WORK TO FIX OUR EMPLOYEES.
GREAT AND I REALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
TO ENSURE THAT YOU AND YOUR
DEPARTMENT OR APPROPRIATELY
RESOURCE. TO DO THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT YOU'VE OUTLINED THAT
THAT ARE ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIALSO
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN THANK YOU
MANAGER.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WELL MY COLLEAGUES ASK ALL THE
QUESTIONS I WANTED TO TO ASK AND
AND DID IT WELL REALLY ENJOYED
OUR CONVERSATION THE OTHER DAY.
AND IT REALLY IT I THINK IT
SHOWN THROUGH DURING OUR
CONVERSATION JUST YOUR PASSION
AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE MEN
IN WHITE WOMEN WHO SERVE WITH
YOU.
AND MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS YOU
KNOW WHERE YOU NEED TO GO IT'S
IT'S A RESOURCES THAT WAS JUST
MISSION BY SENATOR ROSS SO I
HOPE WE DO OUR JOB HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO GET TO THE
RESOURCES -- NELLY FREEMEN WOMEN
BUT TO ALSO TO PROTECT ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES YOU GUYS
RECENTLY DID A GREAT JOB ON THE
STAND FIRE THOMAS FIRE.
AND JUST REALLY THAT THANKFUL
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND SERVICE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
YOUR CONFIRMATION TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS OF MY
COLLEAGUES IS AS WELL I FEEL
LIKE WE'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION.
FOR A COUPLE OF DECADES ACTUALLY.
I I REALLY FEEL HONORED TO BE IN
THE POSITION I'M IN TODAY.
BEFORE YOU AS THE CHAIR THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
I HAVEN'T SPENT TWO THOUSAND
THROUGH.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT I YOU ARE ARE
KEY LIAISON FROM CAL FIRE WITH
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
I AND HAS -- WE WERE LISTENING
TO YOUR COMMENTS I GET TEXT
MESSAGES BLOWING UP FROM STAFF
MEMBERS IN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
ARE ACTUALLY ONE WHO WAS CHRIS
KEY HAVE STAFF MEMBER BUT WHO
CAME OUT OF THE CITY AND WORKS
WITH ME TODAY.
WHO REMINDED ME OF THE MORE
ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND THREE
IN THE CEDAR FIRE IN? TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN IN THE WHICH FIRE.
I THAT COST THE WHICH FIRE I
THINK WAS THE LARGEST X. MOST
EXPENSIVE FIRE UNTIL TODAY.
OUR WHICH WAS IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY SO.
WE TALKED ABOUT -- BUFFER ZONES
IN GENERAL PLANS AND WE DEALT
WITH ALL OF THAT ON AS I WAS ON
THE CITY COUNCIL IN SAN DIEGO
DURING THOSE REALLY DIFFICULT
YEARS WE EVACUATED ALMOST FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE.
I DURING THE WHICH FIRE.
I WE LEARN FROM TWO THOUSAND
THREE AND WE HAD QUITE A
PARTNERSHIP.
OF WITH YOU AND OBVIOUSLY YOUR
FAMILY.
AT THAT TIME SO I I I COULDN'T
SAY ANY MORE THAN MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE EXCEPT THAT WE DO HAVE TO
FOCUS.
ON SOME OF THE ISSUES AS THE
BEST.
SYSTEM ALMOST IN THE WORLD.
OUR WHEN WE SEE OUR ON MUTUAL
AID REALLY PUSHED TO THE BRINK.
WHEN WE SEE THAT WE NEED
UPGRADED EQUIPMENT AND
ADDITIONALLY THE THE ISSUES
AROUND?
I MENTAL HEALTH -- THE ABILITY
SUPPORT OUR FIREFIGHTERS.
YOU KNOW I'M REALLY THRILLED
THAT YOU'RE HERE TODAY SO I CAN
ADD MUCH MORE.
THAN MY CONGRADULATIONS OF MY
THANKS ON BEHALF OF MY COMMUNITY --
AND NOW OF COURSE FOR THE WHOLE
STATE -- SO WERE HONORED.
AND I'M HONORED TO BE -- ONE OF
THE FIRST VOTES.
I TO PUT YOU IN THAT POSITION --
WITH THAT I WANT TO SEE WHO'S
HERE -- TO WAY IN FROM MEMBERS
OF OUR PUBLIC SOMEONE A START
WITH MEMBERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT.
YOU WANNA GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND BRIEF COMMENTS
WE WOULD APPRECIATE THAT.
RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON STACY
HEATING WITH A RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THIRTY SIX ROLE
COUNTY STATEWIDE.
AND REALLY PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF CHIEF PORTER
WHEN WE FIRST MET WE'VE WORKED
TOGETHER.
FOR YEARS NOW FIRST ON THE TREE
MORTALITY TASK FORCE AND NOW THE
FORCED HEALTH TASK FORCE IN.
WHEN WE FIRST MET HE WAS FROM
SAN DIEGO YOU KNOW WE GAVE HIM A
LITTLE BIT OF A SIDE I BEING THE
RURAL COUNTIES BUT?
HE IMMEDIATELY STARTED TO REACH
OUT TO REMEMBER COUNTIES AND
BUILD UP THAT TRUST AND LEARN
OUR ISSUES AND YOU KNOW WE'VE
HAD A LOT OF HIGH SEVERITY
WILDFIRES IN OUR MEMBER COUNTIES
AND THROUGH THESE PAST FEW YEARS
OUR COUNTIES HAVE REALLY GOTTEN
TO KNOW CHIEF PORTER AND THAT.
TRUST IS THERE AN AND THAT WE
COULDN'T BE HAPPIER WITH HIS
APPOINTMENT AND TO SUPPORT HIM
GOING FORWARD AND CONTINUING
THIS PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL FIRE
THAT WE'VE BUILT UP OVER THE
YEARS SO -- WE FULLY SUPPORT HIM
HERE TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIRMAN TERRY MAKAYLA
THERE AND READ NECESSITY IT'S
WE'VE REPRESENTED CAL FIRE LOCAL
TWO EIGHT EIGHT ONE FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS.
AND WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT
IT'S THE TIMES THAT MAKE THE
PERSON.
AND TOM PORTER IS ENTERING IN AS
DIRECTOR OF CAL FIRE IT PERHAPS
THE MOST DIFFICULT TIME IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
FIRES THAT WE WOULD HAVE FOUGHT
UNIMAGINABLE JUST TEN YEARS AGO
RACK THE LANDSCAPE NOW.
AND WE DO HAVE FIREFIGHTERS.
WHO LEAVE THEIR HOME IN MARCH OR
IN IN MAY AND DON'T COME HOME
BUT FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS?
UNTIL NOVEMBER.
I WANT TO SAY THAT.
TOM CAME TO OUR BOARD.
AND THE SAME CANDOR IN THE SAME
DECENCY IN THE SAME INTELLECT IN
THE SAME COMMITMENT.
THAT HE IS SHOWING YOU HE SHOWED
OUR BOARD.
AND HE DEALT WITH THE DIFFICULT
ISSUES.
LAST YEAR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET FOR
CALIFORNIA WENT UP ONE FIFTH TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
BECAUSE OF OVERTIME.
AND I CAN TELL YOU ARE
FIREFIGHTERS THEY LIKE SOME OF
THAT OVER TIME BUT THEY DON'T
WANT ALL OF IT.
AND WE DO NEED MORE ENGINES ARE
SENATOR ROTH THIS ISN'T THE TIME
I KNOW TO DO THE BUDGET PLAY.
BUT WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT WE HAVE THIRTY ONE FEWER
ENGINES AND CAL FIRE THAN WE HAD
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WE HAVE
FEWER RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH THE
pTHREE AND A HALF MILLION
BUILDINGS.
WE NEED STRONG LEADERSHIP WE
NEED A LEADER THAT WILL WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE UNION
THAT CARES DEEPLY ABOUT THE
FIREFIGHTERS.
AND I THINK WE HAVE THAT IN TOM
PORTER.
I WILL TAKE BACK TO MY CLIENTS
TO THE FIREFIGHTERS.
WHAT I THINK IS PERHAPS OE OF
THE MOST SALIENT POINTS MADE
TODAY?
AND THAT IS THE TOM PORTER SAID.
WHEN HE LEAVES HERE HE WANTS TO
FIX ONE THING?
HE WANTS TO FIX THE JOB FOR THE
FIREFIGHTERS WERE ON THE LINE.
AND CHIEF PORTER AND MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THE
COMMITMENT OF TWO EIGHT EIGHT
ONE THEY WE WILL CERTAINLY WORK
WITH YOU GOD BLESS YOU TOM IT'S
A BIG TASK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MEMBER TOM MEMBERS
PROMISE OF PACIFIC FOREST TRUST --
FOR CONSERVATION AND RESTORATION
ORGANIZATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF WORKING
WITH REPORTER FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND I WOULD ECHO
ALL THE KIND THINGS THAT THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS HAVE SAID.
ON A PLEASURE TO WORK WITH AND I
THINK THAT.
THE BREADTH EXPERIENCE THAT HE
BRINGS THE POSITION BOTH ON THE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE BUT ALSO ON
THE FOREST RESTORATION SIDE OF
THE EQUATION I APPRECIATE THE
FOCUS APARTMENT ON LOOKING AT
LAND USE AND REALLY.
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
FIRE IS ONE OF THE PLACES WHERE
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REALLY GOING
TO AFFECT CALIFORNIA MOST
DRASTICALLY AND FIRST.
AS GONNA REQUIRE A PRESS ON ALL
OF THOSE DIFFERENT THINGS
SIMULTANEOUSLY WE'RE NOT GOING
TO FIX IT JUST WITH THE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE OR JUST WITH
LAND USE OR JUST WITH FORCE
RESTORATION.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT SORT OF
INTEGRATED THINKING THAT'S
EIGHTY FOUR BRINGS THE TABLE.
VERY MUCH SUPPORT OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR SINGLE PICKY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT GIVEN
THE DRAMATIC INCREASE IN
WILDFIRES NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF
ACRES BUT IN TERMS OF SEVERITY.
LOSS OF LIFE AND DAMAGE PROPERTY
THERE IS A NEED MORE THAN EVER
TO ENSURE THAT SOMEONE WITH
EXPERIENCE IN BOTH FORCE
MANAGEMENT.
AND FIRE SUPPRESSION FILL THE
POSITION OF DIRECTOR FOR STREAM
FIRE PROTECTION.
AND WE BELIEVE IT TOM PORTER IS
THE RIGHT FIT FOR THIS JOB THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M TASHA NEWMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA URBAN FOREST
COUNCIL.
AND WE TO HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
WORKING WITH MISTER PORTER DOWN
IN SAN DIEGO AND REALLY ENJOYED
THAT EXPERIENCE.
WE WERE ABLE TO MEET WITH HIM
RECENTLY AND TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THE ISSUES AFFECTING URBAN
FORESTRY WE KNOW A LOT OF THE
FOCUS IS ON WILD FIRE IN
FORESTED LANDS BUT THERE ARE.
DEAD AND DYING TREES IN THE
URBAN FOREST AS WELL AND SO.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
CHIEF ORDER ON THOSE ISSUES
GOING FORWARD WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON -- MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CARL LUNDEN HERE ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA BY MASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE THIS IS THE CESSATION
TRACER THE STATE'S WOODY BIOMASS
POWER GENERATORS THIS ONE ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION.
RIGHT GUY RIGHT TIME WE SPORTS
REPORTERS WELL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRO TEM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JAY ZIEGLER WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY -- WE ARE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF TOM
PORTER AS THAT EXCELLENT CHOICE
TO BE THE CHIEF IT CAL FIRE.
WE HAVE HAD EXPERIENCE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS AS WE WORK
AND COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGIES. TO
ADDRESS FIRE THREATS TO
COMMUNITIES AND FORCE ACROSS THE
STATE AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE SKILLS THAT -- THAT TOM
BRINGS AS NOTED BY THE PRIOR
SPEAKERS BUT ALSO IN REACHING
OUT TO WIDER STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
AND REALLY UNDERSTANDING THE
IMPORTANCE OF BRIBE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT IN MAKING THESE
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGIES WORK.
AND AS WE TEAR FROM THESE THIRTY
FIVE PRIORITY AT COMMUNITY
PROTECTION PROJECTS -- THAT THE
PRINT DEPARTMENT HAS IDENTIFIED
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AS ITS
FIRST LINE OF ATTACK -- IN
IMPLEMENTING SOME OF THE CHARTER
OF SB NINE A ONE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING OUT WITH TOM IN THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE LEGISLATURE.
IN REALLY DRIVING THESE LARGER
LANDSCAPE INTEGRATED FIRE.
MANAGEMENT SOLUTION SETS -- AND
WE FEEL LIKE A TIME IS REALLY
THE RIGHT PERSON IS BROUGHT THE
RIGHT.
BY AND BOTH IN THE DEPARTMENT AS
WELL AS AMONG DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE THE
STRATEGIES.
BETTER UNDERSTOOD AND ALSO MORE
DURABLE OVERTIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M WORKING
CAMINO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IS IN SUPPORT
OF SCONCE CONFIRMATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF THE HUMBLE MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES AND WE FULLY
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF
MISTER PORTER WE ADVOCATED HIS
NOMINATION.
TO GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
HIM IN HIS NEW CAPACITY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE A MARK LORENZO IN
VENTURA COUNTY FIRE CHIEF ALSO
CHAIR OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CONTRACT COMPANIES WE'VE BEEN A
STRONG PARTNER WITH CAL FIRE AND
TOM PORTER. FOR MANY MANY
DECADES AND AND TOM AND CAL FIRE
SUPPORT S. ALL HAD HARDLY BUT
THE THOMAS FIRE IN THE MOST
RECENT WAS THE FIRE AND JUST ON
BEHALF OF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
FIRE DEPARTMENT IN THE
ASSOCIATION OF CONTRACT TENNIS
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT ON
DEPLOYMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY IF
THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
I WOULD INVITE SOMEONE FORWARD
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
I WILL ACCEPT THE MOTION BY
SENATOR ROTH MADAM SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
SENATORS BATES.
I AM MONNING.
MONNING AYE RAFI.
RAFI AYE WILK WILK AYE ATKINS
AYE ATKINS AYE IT IS UNANIMOUS
CONGRADULATIONS
.
AND THANK YOU ALL AND MEDAL
PROGRAM.
SEE YOU ON A PLANE SOMETHING AT
THAT.
AND WITH THAT WE INVITE YOU ALL
TO LEAVE SO WE CAN GO INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION BUT
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE FAMILY --
AS WELL.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE